a lot of you've been asking me what's
going on with be friends cards obviously
I'm building this Pokemon meet Sesame
Street IP and it's multi-platform
obviously there's nfts but there's also
animations there's also collectible toys
and collectible cards are popping off go
check on eBay super fired up about it
I'll be at the national in Chicago the
last week of July the whole week please
come and check that but for a lot of you
that love Pokemon love Magic the
Gathering love sports cards
um this is something worth checking out
like we're having a lot of fun there's
gonna be a lot of pack breaking nights
there's gonna be a lot of meetups and I
know a lot of you love that flip life so
check it out Link in BIO if you want
more in-depth information I'm humbled
you can imagine what this means to 15
year old me and uh
pretty damn cool check it out